you can make just about anything with a  3d printer these days even medical  devices and implants but most of these  objects are rigid recreating complex  soft tissues like the structures that  make up the human heart is much more  complicated Carnegie Mellon researchers  are meeting the challenge by injecting  hydrogels made of proteins and  carbohydrates into similar gels that  support the new tissue as it prints  first they make 3d images of the tissue  and use computer-aided design to create  a template then the printer goes to work  in voila in under an hour a functional  coronary artery is complete it's even  capable of transporting fluids like  blood the researchers have also printed  an anatomically correct miniature human  brain you might not be able to order a  new brain anytime soon but soft tissue  replacements customized to each  patient's medical needs could be just  around the corner  you